one of the greatest to ever play the
game certainly at the collegiate level
he's Doug Flutie how are you Doug I'm
doing fine I've been wanting to reach
out to you for a while because everybody
in the NFL is trying to get in the minds
of how we've changed playing this game
at the quarterback position you're a guy
who's been looking at this obviously for
the collegiate level professionally you
played it professionally and I'm
wondering what do you think of when you
hear that Kyle Amari checked a positive
box by measuring in at five ten and an
eighth of the combine chuckle and laugh
and wish I could have been 5-10 minutes
per day to get my big check I think it
just it's the nature of the game now you
know I I met Tyler at Heisman weekend I
thought he I thought he's a little
taller than I thought it was at least a
full inch inch and a half taller to me
and you know with the spread offenses
the way team Shuster quarterbacks a
runner now athleticism is look there's
an advantage an asset and it still comes
down to the mental aspect of the game
now I still have to be able to win from
the pocket but the with the spread
offenses owning stuff and RPO is just an
asset so when you were trying to
checkboxes to play in the National
Football League
I mean how difficult was it for you you
couldn't change how tall you were Doug
I'm wondering what it was like for you
back in that day you know I what I had
was the USFL sitting there knocking on
the doorstep so I had an opportunity and
when it came to combine I'd already
signed the contract so when it came to
the combo with the USFL right I I didn't
go to the combines I was projected
anywhere from her first seven I had no
idea what the NFL was Fenton so if we I
took you know the burden hand and I
think for me and the bottom line is this
I always thought it was you know I've
known the game from 510 my whole life I
don't know it any other way this is the
tannest point I've had I don't know why
it's going to be a problem at the next
one
they never really I don't think the enof
however really measured me or I never
went for them or any of that because I
just kind of blew it all off and when
went to the USFL and then when I came
back I got my opportunities to play yeah
obviously you know when the Bears will
get to that in a second did you when you
sign I mean you win the Heisman Trophy
in 84 I just want to go down this this
wormhole for a little bit here you win
the Heisman Trophy in 84 did you meet
with the current president in the United
States before you saw him with the New
Jersey generals did you did that
actually go down Doug we talked over the
phone a couple of times while
negotiations were going on
he was my owner the entire you know that
year it's whether it was going to dinner
or other save it's kind of weird for me
to think now I hurt to Walker and I were
both on that New Jersey generals team
there were a lot of big games on that
team it's Brian and yeah I mean from a
football standpoint it was just too much
money to pass up at the time he made me
dice paid professional football player
in America at the time so I just decided
to bypass the risk or what the NFL
looked at there's a risk with me and
yeah hang out with Donald Trump for a
year and Hannah I bet you did and then
and then the Bears came knocking on your
door Doug I mean what what what happened
there what happened there was uh in the
second year
Trump tried to sue the NFL and sit for
monopoly and the league ended up not
playing and I didn't become free I was
still in the contract so anything I
would sign for was going to be kind of
supplemental or you know it was gonna be
anyway so I signed a smaller deal with
Chicago Chicago had traded for my rights
with the LA had had drafted me the Rams
they traded my rights over Chicago
because they were looking for a
quarterback at the time because Renee
was banged up I got in at the end so
she's in a played in Chicago
Flutie here on the Rich Eisen show it is
just an amazing journey
obviously Duggan it's just remarkable to
me that that height and playing the
quarterback position with a sense of
athleticism and savvy and smarts is now
a commodity where Russell Wilson is
about to potentially be the highest-paid
quarterback in the game and we're seeing
a kid who's gonna be drafted first
overall and nobody's batting an eyelash
about it it's the difference the
difference is there are a lot of guys
that are undersized to have success in
college and then just don't translate
the mental aspect the game is number one
number two is the arm strength the
smaller guys some guys cannot throw ball
some guys just can't the arm doesn't
carry over you know when you look at
Kyler Murray he grabs that thing lets it
rip like a baseball I mean he just turns
it loose it's a natural throwing motion
he's got plenty of arm strength can make
all the throws so then the next step is
busy at the mental capacity the coaches
that I've talked to say you know with
flying colors so now all of a sudden you
got it I can be successful and he's got
all this athleticism subdued so it's
gonna be exciting and and Russell was
that way I mean for Russell to go from
North Carolina to Wisconsin or NC State
to Wisconsin and start and star in that
one transfer season you know he had to
pick things up in a hurry you know he
had to be a leader type so all those
boxes get checked and then the Heights
not as big a deal
Doug Flutie here in the Rich Eisen show
what do you think Kyler Murray's biggest
challenge is gonna be then you're gonna
follow in the Blitz package is your face
and this is a Bill Belichick he'll do to
keep you in the pocket you know what but
Bill always did to me when I played
against him and whether a few other
coaches have done they always try to
bring the five they're gonna bring a
fifth rusher they're gonna push the
pocket yell at their defensive end don't
you dare get deeper than the quarterback
if you know the worst place in the field
to be is behind the quarterback then he
steps up town he's off and running
you're defending the other goal line and
that's that's bills line you know so
they try to push the pocket make you
throw out of a well and have to see
through the idea was spread now
you're spreading the field you're
sending out the number of people they
can bring and the passing lanes are even
bigger and Drew Brees has made a living
pinging shotgun getting depth and
getting everybody out in the route you
know you start keeping a tight end in or
a back in the block well that's a to
more bodies in there on your side and
two more bodies on their side there
clutter up the picture three release
people get him out so what's the biggest
miss Nomar for free quarterbacks who are
short in stature Doug what do you think
hey you know the - can be a problem but
you played the game from your height
your entire life you've seen it from
that perspective
I just don't think especially just that
the vision is not really that big a deal
and I think that even the tall guys I
remember went out on a Monday night game
giving three seconds passes battle back
in the face and he's suppose like
six-four six-five not a lot of work was
mixing of his height the majority of
passes you know the majority of passes
to get batted down or just you know
there's a guy the defensive end to the
pass from the quarterback gets a hand up
so that every quarterback throws between
bodies and true lanes and the big
difference where there is a problem if
you have a normal drop back pass where
you're doing a full field read your over
to the right side with your eyes you
instinctively slide and move a little
and find a little alleyway to see what
you're looking at there and get your
read and when it's not there I always
had to move towards the back side round
or move towards the check down to find
them and get it down so once the initial
1 2 - 1 - 2 - 3 is in there and you're
going from front side the back side a
lot of times if you just turn it's gonna
look like a wall to you and you got to
refine some lanes or glues to those like
that's the only time that it ever became
an issue for me Doug
a few more minutes left with Doug here
on the Rich Eisen show when you played
for Belichick what's the one thing that
you picked up at the very end of your
career talen and I'm not just talking
about doing a dropkick in a game which
was pretty awesome to save would you
pick up from that the did the thing that
amazed me was the amount of information
bill would take in in a game play early
in the week to prepare his game plan he
has people reading every article every
comment that comes from an opposing
locker room gets read filtered through
the amount of information that you can
pick up from all the interviews the
other players are doing and things they
say about you know a game plan about
they don't mean to be telling it but
there is a lot of information that is
given away that's why built ala check is
the most boring interview and in the
country bill is not going to give you
one thing he's going to get on top of
his guys not to say a word be generic be
bland don't give away information
because there is a ton of information
giving away and it amazed me in their
scouting reports and their game plans
how detailed they could be and how right
on they could be because of information
that you know came out of a press
conference of loose lips in that regard
can you do you have an example did you
remember that you were like wow okay so
it was like in buried in paragraph 12 of
somebody's game right up from four weeks
before I mean is that jog the memory
where you're like okay that was really
something yeah I I can't
I can't come up with specific one there
but I do remember the Warren Thurman
Thomas being animated Herman would
always be animated when he's running a
screen he'd like to try to pretend he's
in pass protection so you're pointing
out the middle linebacker for the weak
side linebacker that type of stuff and
and I played with Thurman and once I saw
it and Bill Scottie report about Thurman
I go that's dead-on that's right every
time we had a screen on all of a sudden
he was like really pointing people out
shuffling us Eaton's moving around and
things like that the information that is
less get a lock the coach is always one
you to turn your PlayBook in before you
travel to the opposing city or turn your
game plans in a lot of guys the worst
mistake I ever made
I dropped my yeah 12 starter plays or 10
starter plays whatever that is sharing
the game in Oakland we jog up out of the
ramp through the opposing teams bench
and over the our sideline across the
field I get there we're getting ready
for opening kickoff I can't find my top
ten play and I had him in my helmet as I
jogged across holding in my hand I ran
back while the kickoff team was walking
on the field I ran back across the field
into the Raiders bench scurried around
the bottom of the pack sound of list of
our top ten plays under their pitch grab
it ran back across the field there's
almost too many men on the kickoff so
you're saying I never lining up like
everybody was lined up for kickoff
looking to me running back across the
field the top 10 plays laying on there I
did everything Bill Belichick is about
with the opposing team with loose lips
and information and Here I am
practically giving the Raiders our first
10 play what was Brady like when you
were there uh tom tom was great
I mean besides being first in last out
hardest worker and all that he had a
knack so I mean you know the football
end of it the IQ all that brilliant but
he had a knack for making everybody feel
like they were important
everybody had a piece of this every you
know the guy that's in the training room
he didn't even practice that week Tom
would go in and have a good comment form
up you did a great job on scout team
last week and you really made us better
and things of that nature I had a
conversation with Tom before it
Indianapolis game we were getting ready
for her where we're doing some
two-minute offensive stuff you know they
played this cover - a little too close
to the goal line
I went up the rail and stick it in there
and in the middle of a no-huddle
two-minute situation Tom checks to a
play on the 15-yard line going in looks
as safety off her second sticks it in
the corner the end zone for touchdown he
came straight off the field to me said
yeah that that's yours you know and
which is total BS because Tom knew what
he
got a hundred times before I got there
and knew but he would acknowledge any
contribution by anyone on the team it
was pretty impressive
Doug Flutie here on the Rich Eisen show
what he got for Irish fans after you
just eyeballed the team for the spring
game this weekend very encouraging
offensive defensible I was really strong
and booked at quarterback it's gonna be
great their linebacker level very own
experience
and it will be very scary if he in book
gets banged up it's there is we're back
you there I just lost we just lost at
the end they're the number one
quarterback Ian Brooke needs to stay
healthy okay
that's you got to figure out okay yeah
guys noticed you were doing that spring
game is this this weekend hey Doug I've
always been meaning to ask you this too
apropos of nothing did you have any say
in what the Flutie flakes were back in
the day did you ever did you have a
really didn't other than once we decided
on it I one of the frozen pizzas first
of all I wanted to be a frozen pizza
what do you mean and they came back with
our biggest profit margin is on us here
at breakfast cereal I said well I love
frosted flakes there we'll make some
kind of sugar flight we'll figure it out
and that that was about the extent of
that conversation and we sold over 6
million boxes okay and then when was the
last time you had a a Flutie flake
haven't been made in 20 years something
on line with what they broke the Flutie
curse in May they also kid broke a
fruity flakes box 20 years old that's
right that's right that's right yeah
yeah yeah I don't know if after 20 years
they probably they probably get soggy
and milk after 20 years maybe you never
know what you say how much we just found
them on eBay Doug $8 $8 Wow
the price of the flakes have gone up
refugio you put the cost of milk it is
to $10 breakfast right there Wow
my gosh probably not real healthy and
you're probably hitting off to the
hospital with twenty year old that's
great Doug really appreciate the call
let's chat down the line anytime you're
in Los Angeles just let me know but
really appreciate the call thanks thanks
you got it
Doug Flutie for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel 239 under
red TV for free on BR live or download
the Rich Eisen show app